you
[Music]
welcome everyone to the last session of
our workshop the first talk will be by
wrong gear from Duke University oh
thanks
thanks for inviting me and thanks for
sticking to the last session so today
I'm going to talk about recent work
about explaining landscape connectivity
of low-cost solutions for multi-layer
nets so this is joint work with rohith's
and young releases an undergrad at Duke
young is a grad student with me and many
people from Princeton Houghton yi-hyun
way and Sam chief drew and is probably
somewhere in the audience yeah right so
so to start with let me just say what is
this landscape connectivity that I was
talking about so this is were also known
as mode connectivity so this is a
phenomena that has been recently
discovered so so phenomena says for
neural networks local minima found by
gradient descent were any other popular
optimization algorithm that you use in
practice so local optima are connected
by simple paths in the parameter space
so if you two can take a look at this
picture so a is one of the local minima
for a neural network B is another local
minimum a sink of B as found by running
gradient descent on a different random
initialization right so this is just the
projection of the parameter space into a
two dimensional space for each one well
I would be more precise later but for
now a and B are just two random local
minima that you were able to find and
the colors are the loss for the value of
the last function so the warmer colors
means the loss in slow and colder colors
means losses high so as you can see if I
go directly between these two solutions
if I do a linear interpolation between
the two there is actually a barrier
between the two it's a loss in the
middle is actually much higher than the
loss at the two endpoints
but the surprising phenomena that was
found in in these papers was that you
can actually connect these two by just
finding a third point by finding an
intermediate point C such that if I go
from A to C and then from C to B then
throughout this entire pass the loss is
low so now I can say what does this
projection this projection is just
because we have three points I project
to the span a fine span of these three
points that that's that's weird this
picture came from right so every point
on this pass is another solution of the
neural network of almost the same cost
so I guess if you were here for Leon's
talk on Monday this might not be super
surprising to you because he was
essentially talking about a very similar
phenomena but let me still explain why
it was very surprising to me when I
first saw it's this property so it's a
reason this is very strange to me when I
first saw the phenomena is because I've
been thinking about these local minima
and symmetry in non convex optimization
roughly speaking for the problems that
we understand there are two types of
problems for which we have some
understanding on the optimization
landscape where the local minima are so
the first type of problems are what I'm
going to call the matrix problems so in
these problems your goal is to find a
low rank matrix and so and the way you
do that is you are going to parameterize
this low rank matrix as the product of
two smaller matrices so you no longer
need to worry about the rank constraint
so this if M can be written as X ax
transpose is automatically low rank but
in this formalization if you find an
optimal solution X star it's not known
to be the unique optimal solution
because you can apply an arbitrary
rotation matrix on top of that solution
and there are many equivalent solutions
right so another type of problem is what
I'm going to call tensor problems I mean
these are not necessarily all about
tensors but but they have the same
symmetry so the goal of these type of
problems is to find K things they can be
say K components of a tensor where K
centers for a clustering or and and so
on so in this case what I care about is
I want to find these casings but I don't
care about the ordering of these casings
it's a it's a set of vectors you can
think about it so in this case I can no
longer apply an arbitrary rotation
matrix to the solution but I can still
apply an arbitrary permutation matrix to
the solution and the solution would be
the same so for these two type of
problems I always think that for matrix
problems I mean because the set of
rotation matrices is kind of connected
it's not exactly because I mean it has
two connected components corresponding
to determinant 1 and minus 1 but it's
still mostly connected only has 2
connected components so I would expect
the picture to look kind of like this
like what we saw in the previous slide
but for the tensor problems because the
equivalent solutions are discrete I've
always been thinking that they should
have these kind of isolated local minima
and in fact it's indeed true that for
the actual tensor problems so you have
these isolated local minima and then the
question is what problem is neural
network well for neural networks because
they are nonlinear Arty's if you just
apply and rotation to your weight
matrices that's not going to give you
the same neural network so I guess
before I was always thinking that neural
networks look more like the tensor kind
of problems where you are trying to look
for components in this case rule B as a
weights often euros right so so then
they might have isolated local minimum
but that was not true right as we saw in
the previous slide
for neural networks that people use in
practice they have connected local
minimum so why is this well tor has been
so there has been some explanation of
this mold connectivity property and
there's the short answer is our prime
transition like like the answer to many
other questions that we heard in this
workshop so it's testing works can
explain a mode connectivity to some
extent so these works basically show
that if the network has special
structure it's either two layer were a
multi-layer neural network but with some
special connections and if the network
is what I will call highly overpriced
then the local min minima are connected
so by highly or privatized I mean the
number of neurons should be larger than
the number of training samples in fact
there's a there needs to be a constant
factor gap but that's not super
important well these are nice but it's a
problem with these explanations is that
neural networks in practice that in the
experiments that I just wrote you they
are not as over parametrize as this
right I mean we we know that neural
networks are almost always over
traumatized but it's not clear whether
the number of neurons needs to be a lot
larger than the number of training
samples usually is enough if the number
of parameters is larger than the number
of training samples and number of
neurons is obviously much smaller than
the number of parameters even for a two
layer neural network so our goal here is
to try to prove a similar result so try
to understand why as a local minima can
be connected in a mildly overcome price
regime and by that I mean the number of
neurons at especially the number of
neurons per layer is smaller than the
number of training samples but maybe the
number of parameters is too larger than
the number of training samples okay
and in general I feel like we we should
start working on this regime for for
many other problems as well okay so so
roughly speaking our is up shows for
neural networks what we observe is
actually not always true so there are
cases we are not all local minima or
global minima are connected you've been
in the or harm tried setting so of
course we already know in the highly
over parametrize setting everything is
connected so here by our parent setting
I mean something that's only mildly
overpower tries on the other hand even
though not all local minima are
connected would we show is that
solutions satisfy some reasonable
property that we will call dropout
stability so these solutions are
actually connected by a path and in the
paper we also show it's possible to
switch this dropout stability notion
with some other notion of stability like
no stability that are that we're used
for proving generalization bounds for
neural networks if you just train some
people you will network is it easy to
test if like local minima collectibles
like intractable oh okay yeah good
question right so so basically you are
asking how easy it is to produce the
first figure that I showed you right how
easy it is to find this pattern special
ID right it actually in practice is
actually surprisingly easy as I said the
pass is just a two line segments so you
can just parameterize the past using the
middle point and you do great in this
and on that and that actually works very
well in practice we I mean we will prove
existence of paths in certain cases but
we are of course very far from proving
like this approach is going to find you
a pass okay sorry
oh yeah I'm going to departure
okay so before going to that definition
let me first just try to talk about the
notation we're setting said we are going
to talk about so for simplicity we are
only going to focus on fully connected
networks but the same thing actually can
be extended to convolutions and other
things so we'll have weight matrices W 1
2 WP so these are just matrices for
different layers non-artists
Sigma which we was young mistress
Randall we get many samples so we hope
to learn a network and the function
computed by the network I'm going to
call that f of theta and theta is the
set of parameters in all of these weight
matrices
what's important is here like in the top
layer in the output layer you don't have
a non-linearity which is also fairly
standard and in the objective so
objective is the training loss so you
just take the average over the loss on
each of your training samples and here L
is just any loss function that as long
as it is convex in terms of the second
parameter here it is okay so either is
square loss or cross-entropy both of
them are ok so our first result shows
that in the mildly over prom tries
regime not all local minimum are
connected we actually give a very
concrete counter example in a very
simple setting so it's just a two layer
neural network and the data X I and why
I is actually generated by a ground
truth neural network with just two
hidden neurons so that means there is a
neural network with two hidden neurons
that can compute Y i given X I so it's a
function is actually very simple we
consider our parameter transition in the
sense that we are going to try to
consider fitting this function with a
two layer neural network with H hidden
neurons and H is much bigger than two H
can be any
constant that speakers on to so would we
show is for neh there exists a data set
with just h+ 2 samples such that the set
off global minimizer's are not connected
so they are exist to local to global
minimizer's and if you want to go from
one to the other you have to pass
something that has a non zero loss and
this could be just like isolated point
so it's doing some small neighbor no
they are not isolated point in general
for example in this case we still have
the number of parameters to be larger
than the number of training samples
right in that case usually you expect
that it's a set of minimizer's to form
some low dimensional manifold but the
question here is whether these manifolds
are globally connected or they have
different connected bones on the number
of connected component we don't have
that tight bond but in some sense this
bond is fairly tight because we we are
just my our number of samples is just
slightly larger than the number of
neurons so we are just slightly in the
my OD or parametrize regime but even in
this case not all the minimizer's are
connected so now since not all the
minimizer's are connected we can ask
what kind of local minimum should be
connected
well first we notice that empirical
results only show that local minima
found by standard optimization
algorithms are connected
it doesn't necessarily like obvi
obviously we cannot enumerate all the
local minima or also global minima of
neural networks so we don't know whether
they are all connected or not and the
local minima found by these standard
optimization algorithms have some
special properties in this in this
workshop previously many people also
talked about what can we say about
solutions that are found by standard
optimization algorithms is closely
connected to the question of
generalization and
it's a regularization there are many
conjectures but the one we are going to
use in this talk it's going to be what
we call rapid stability so what is
dropout stability so we say a network is
epsilon dropout stable if we can zero
out 50% of the nodes at every layer and
we we are allowed to rescale the other
weights of other neurons appropriately
if doing this only increases its loss by
at most Epsilon that's requires it like
for every zeroing out observing out
there exists a zeroing out so if you do
drop out training kind of the guarantee
you are expecting is for a random
zeroing out of 50% of the nodes your
performance is still good what we
require is actually bigger than that we
only require there exists a dropout of
50% of nodes this is it's like saying
you can prune your neural network to
remove half of the neurons at every
layer yeah so here's just a picture
representation it is a sergeant all
Network
but after removing half of the neurons
at every layer it won't look like this
for technical reasons we don't just
require dropping hot which is for both
layers you can also drop out a subset of
layers from the top to bottom so in this
example you can also just drop out top
layer we saw touching the bottom layer
okay so what we can show is if we have
two parameters for this neural network
theta a and theta B if they are both
dropout stable then we can construct a
path between them and the maximum loss
on this path is going to be less or
equal to the maximum loss at the
endpoints plus epsilon where epsilon is
the parameter in this drop hot stable
definition yeah so this is actually for
any number of layers okay so I so in the
remainder of the talk I'm going to show
you roughly how we can prove such a
thing so at a high level
because we are assuming a positive
stability to go from this solution
number one to solution number two there
are just three high-level steps so first
we will go from this network to its
dropout version and then the last step
is going to be we go from a dropout
version of the second network to to the
network in itself now the middle step is
actually fairly simple because now both
of these networks have only half of
their capacity right only half of the
neurons are active the other half of the
neurons are all set to zero so I can
actually linearly interpolate between
these two neural networks and these two
sides of the neural network will behave
independently of each other
so the output I'm going to have is going
to be a linear combination of the
outputs and we know if since the since
the objective is convex in the final
output this intermediate step I can just
do a linear interpolation and things are
going to be good so the things that we
really need to worry about is how to
connect a network with its dropout
version and I'm not going to show you it
but in general doing a direct linear
interpolation in this case is not going
to work because the loss function is not
convex in in the in terms of the weights
so how can we connect a network with its
dropout version our main observation is
there are two ways you can connect
things you can use two types of types of
line segments so we say a type a line
segment is if there are two networks
that both have low loss and they only
differ in the top layer weight so all
the previous layers they have the same
weight but the top layer weights are
different then we can linearly
interpolate detention why because the
loss function is actually convex in
terms of the layer weight of the top
layer so but of course if I
we use type a line segments I can never
change any of the layers at the bottom
so I need another two so this type B
line segment says if a group of neurons
do not have any outgoing edges so if
they don't output anything then
obviously these neurons are not useful
so I can change their incoming edges to
anything that's arbitrary right it will
not change the output of the network so
obviously the loss will also not change
so we will just alternate between these
two types of line segments and we'll see
how we can construct a pass from a
neural network to his dropout version
yeah so we will recurse from the top
layer we will use type B moves to
prepare for the next type a move so I
will show you a concrete example you
don't need to look at the pass here so
but what's important here is well let's
talk about the notation so so these are
the three weight matrices this one l3
and r3 is the top layer weight and this
is middle layer rate and this is a lay
weights for the bottom layer I've
partitioned these matrices into blocks
because basically I'm thinking of I'm
partitioning the neurons into two halves
at every layer and I'm going to drop out
the right half of every layer so so in
our paper we actually have a pass of
seven steps that's mostly therefore
because we want to give a general pass
that that's good for induction but
actually for the 3 layer Network you
only need these five steps so let's see
what what's going on yeah so so the
first step is fairly simple so I have
this network I will just change the top
layer weight so that I no longer have
any connection through the right half
after neuron so this is basically a
equivalent to dropping out half of the
neuron only at the top layer which by
assumption is something that's good
and I'm these two networks only
different in the top layer rates so I
can directly interpolate between them
and now since the screen part no longer
have any output I can actually change
its input to whatever I want so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to change the
input for these new rows to be two times
all - so basically kind of doing drop
out on this layer already but doing this
doesn't change the objective function
because these these things are not
outputting anything
so this it was if was active is still
this part of the network but this part
of the network is prepared for the next
step so in the next step I'm just going
to flip the top layer ways from the left
to right and I can do that because
obviously the first Network has slow
loss according to our assumption the
second network is actually equivalent to
this network which is just a drop out
version where both layers have their
neurons removed so the two endpoints are
good and they only differ in the top
layer weights so I can go from here to
here by a gesture linear interpolation
and the final step is just now that this
part of the neurons no longer have any
output I'm just going to zero out their
weights so at the end I have this
network which is equivalent to a dropout
version of the original Network of
course this is only a proof or
illustration for a three layer neural
network but you can do the same
procedure for a multi-layer neural
network and and the result will follow
from an induction so we did some
experiments on this so the past that we
construct are not as good as the past
that people were able to find in
practice so here
our two paths that we were able to find
so the first one is for a smaller scale
things on amnesty using a three layer
convolutional neural network along
amnesty on this small example things are
fairly good the loss and accuracy are
fairly constant allowance of paths but
in the bigger scale experiment on the
CFR 10 dataset using the vgg network
it's actually harder to find a pass
mostly because so here as you can see in
the middle the loss is actually kind of
large and the accuracy becomes lower
note that this is too much better than
the direct interpolation direct
interpolation has a loss that's much
larger than point two so the main reason
for not getting this good reason is for
vgg 11 if you do drop out on all the
layers which is required by our serums
then the performance axe actually drops
fairly significantly especially if you
do drop out on many of the top layers it
really doesn't change the performance
but once you start doing drop our towns
of first or second layer the performance
becomes much worse well not much worse
but significantly worse question this
picture you construct the pass based on
that you'll see you're constructing just
now or some other measure yes so this is
exactly according to the theorem that I
just showed you if you have a local
minimum and how do you test whether it's
a dropout stable local minimum or not
well I guess the existential version is
hard to test but what what we can what
we do here is we actually just randomly
drop out half of the neuron so that you
can efficiently test I I do suspect if
we have a better way of proving prunings
and your own neurons to have to produce
a better a small neural network then we
would get better performance but we we
did
have that okay so just to sum up for
neural networks we can show that not all
local or global minima are connected
even in the or from trend-setting but on
the other hand solutions that satisfy
some nice properties like dropout
stability are actually connected but
there are too many open problems here so
first obviously the pass found by this
property according to our serum there
are few more complicated than the pass
found in practice it's a path we
construct it has many line segments and
in the proof that I showed you the
number of line segments is going to
scale linearly as the number of layers
in practice you just need two line
segments right and also paths are known
to exist in practice even if the
solutions are not as drop-offs stable as
we have hoped for example if you can
look at the experiment on C far right so
if you just run the empirical algorithm
you can actually find that very nice
nice pass there but I guess what I'm
mostly interesting and interested about
is can we leverage this mod connectivity
property to design better optimization
algorithms because naively this property
seems to say something about
optimization that you you would at least
not stock could not be completely stuck
at a local minimum because you are
connected to the global minima but it
doesn't give you any algorithmic
guarantee because you might still be at
a very flat local minima so the
convexity property is that Liane talked
about on Monday is actually a stronger
property because it means that you can
have a small descent locally so yeah if
we if it's possible to prove the
stronger result about the connectivity
then that would definitely have some
algorithmic implications Thanks
patients from this plush Rome so
accuracy was at range no test so all of
these things are on training yeah hi
this midpoint doesn't--you
generalization a lot I it actually gives
similar generalization so the plot on
test is very similar to the plot on
train is why I have no access to three
gives you actually medium of the
generalize well yeah I have no
explanation for that but that's
empirically observed they don't yeah so
there's one other step that I didn't
describe so obviously if they're dropout
patterns are not the same in the middle
you need to do some permutations to make
sure they it's a dropout on different on
this drawing subset of things so then
you can do the linear interpolation so
zoo but that's not very hard because you
have many 0 neurons view so you can use
them as intermediate points to swap
other neurons
yeah that's that's what's presented in
the previous work yeah I mean in in the
papers they did it for C far I think
yeah maybe I missed it but did you give
the proof of the first theorem
oh no I I did I didn't can you say yeah
I guess the intuitively to prove that
they are not connected we actually
construct to load to global minimum so
basically you have two kinds of features
one kind of feature
so actually one kinds of feature gives
you the ground truth solution but it
relies on cancellation so you have post
positive and nectar
coefficients on the second layer the
other set of features are you need many
more of them but they only have positive
weights on the second layer so then you
can show to go from first type to the
second type you need to have some zeros
in the in the top layer and then that
you can show that at that point it is
not going to have a low loss our next
speaker is Givens really
he's from some superposition of stanford
ins at sea and CMU i don't know with
what coefficients yeah coefficients is
like jewelry okay thanks for inviting me
thanks for coming to the talk and today
i'm going to talk about the first wolf
or the most simple example of our
parametrization and that's usually the
key of this talk is simple so it is
going to be extremely simple which means
that say example is really the most
simple example or parameterization yeah
so wait this is not really working maybe
let's just do it in that way so or maybe
like let me try sorry you guys saw the
background because this is my wife's
laptop it's not me so this you will see
on that picture not me
okay yes so what is our parametrization
as you all know it's just by having much
more parameters in the network as you
said it's not more neurons but more
parameters in our neural nets and
necessary which means that you have more
parameters than the number of training
data or you'll have more parameters than
the minimum number of parameter to
represent the target function for
example your target function can be
represent and your network of two
neurons but you use two thousand but you
have a million training examples that's
also kind of over parameterization and
so it improves the performance of the
neural network in both training and
I see kind of like this you'll have a
small data set and the large neural
network is better than a small neural
network so it's common phenomena and
then what is the most simple example of
a privatization that you can tell your
kids in high school
so this is the example which means that
you have a target network that looks
like this you have a cooler network with
low activation and so you'll have waste
AI star and WI star and the input is in
dimension D and the hidden neurons are
in dimension D and all the WS are for
normal writers and all the AIS are -1
and 1 so this is like a target network
you want to learn and all the
coefficients are some randomly so this
is a super good Network okay and then
you have n equal to poly d training
examples of this that are excise are all
Gaussian so everything is super good and
very simple and why I what the labels
are just the value of the target network
and then you want to use a target
network of exactly the same form so you
have D hidden neurons and they are
trained using our two laws and your HDD
or the set of waste AI and WI starting
from random initialization and actually
the trinium process doesn't work
it was stuck at a bad local minima so
even if there exists a I star and WI
star so there is your there is zero loss
solution global minima but you cannot
run them by a proper parametrization
even in this super simple sighting and
but using your target Network a form
that has much more neurons
I'm neurons like M is equal to Pauly D
actually you just need little bit larger
than these they read without rules
Remy SVD over the set of parameters
starting from random initialization your
trinium works and the generalization
works okay so this is the most simple
example to G look something like 10 are
yeesh but that's not all here we are for
know again structure
in practice you'll just need a leash so
this is the most simple example
everything is super simple just like
this picture so have this target Network
the input is caution super simple so the
linear is unitary super simple and in
relevance linear and then you use the
same structure network like this is the
proper learning it doesn't work and then
you use the or parametrize network which
is much larger than your ground truth
then it works okay so is the number
generation number of y iterations o is
going to be polynomial ya polynomial in
D so any is equal to apology okay so
that's the most simple example is the
unify discussions the hidden weights are
unitary and linear subclass minus 1 so
it's super simple
ok this love for example everyone knows
it for a couple of years and it's also
reported to empirically for example in
in Roma's paper so now the question the
real question is can we actually prove
it so can we formally prove that's the
over parametrization does help in both
linear and generalization in this super
simple example and and more importantly
what is the fundamental reason behind
the over parameterization that is
helpful and so let's start with the
fireworks on or Parma tradition and they
are going to be fundamentally different
from this work that's why we start with
that so what is the fireworks the
fireworks on world parametrization there
are many works on the connection between
or parameterization and your attentions
kernel for example you can see my talk I
Simon's is according to the ranking is
the 17th to be done
talk so at Berkeley what does this say
just says when the following oath
condition hosts
I don't know is that we'll have for
harmonization which means that's a
polynomial over parameterization so
there are two Oh in this one and then
we'll have proper learning rate sorry
maybe I switched sorry it's a it's not
proper learning rate is properly
initialization sorry I made a mistake
so you have proper initialization as
small learning rate and then learning a
neural network we are actually
essentially reduced to learning is your
time to internal which is convex but
according to my paper with Zoe one it's
a newer tank i Sakura reason your
tangent kernel cannot learn target
function with Radwell activation in the
new more numerous Pauly D accuracy when
the input is caution so um when the
target network let me have one simple
value so you so you have a simple so
have one value as the target function
the input is Scotian so if you use ng
case and you would need like exponential
indeed number of training data to the
reefs so it's if you have poly D
training data it's definitely not the
regime of and decays so it's different
from so our work cannot be explained by
NDK so that's it's a message okay and
there are also prior works such as given
proper parametrized neural network and a
good initialization not a random
initialization which means that your
waist has spectral norm for example zero
one differ from W star to have a warm
star so in running a three D over W
works
note that W stars are unitary so the
nuke spectral norm is one and you really
have to be much closer to W star and
random initialization in order to the
trinium to work it's a proper party
transition but you need warm star
otherwise if you don't have warm stars
and it will scatter and so this holds
for like given W being adversarial but
close always like oh sorry yeah I was
Sarah but close
but wsr has to be unitary or closely or
neither so according to Michael : this
is a snapshot dump result which I agree
and it's a result of myself so I can
agree with that so and and there are
other works for example given proper a
parameterization and you use a different
loss function and you reduce a different
learner network and you'll switch back
to rally you do with all these tricks
then it works
it's called landscape design and
according to their paper analyzing the
original problem is technically
challenging and the risk the solution
can be potentially enlightening and
whatever so it's a it's not an easy
problem okay that's a message and also
there are like works that says like
given exponential amount of over
parameterizations and noisy as GD works
but if you use the exponential amount of
over parameterizations and you run
linear regression or feature makings
it's also works so there's no advantage
of neural network compared to like
convex problem if you have exponentially
money of numerals so now that Keith's
advantage is polynomial in this simple
example so here is the summary of our
work so you give a target network of the
form tableaus I've started essentially
as what we say but with a linear term
and it is more general than the simple
example because R can be anything
smaller than D so you can have some
missing notes and AI stars they don't
need to be plus minus ones they can have
some constant condition number and then
you have a learner network of the same
type for this over parametrized and the
old harmonization is polynomial and the
number of training data is polynomial
saying we're a mini batch a 3d starting
from random initialization with the
lower polynomial learning rate it's
reached generalization
our polynomial after polynomial learning
the iteration yes the questions first of
all dislike parameters of the original
network they're random or can be
anything I say anything so why do say
it's more general so you basically
prohibit small a is right yeah you
prohibit small eyes and yeah but just
general but originally the most simple
example a eyes are just a plasma and
here the WI stars are can be arbitrary I
stars can be arbitrary but table yousa
have to be also problematic in some way
or sorry small a eyes would be
problematic in our cognition number may
be problematic maybe not is just a
matter of the proof that we can only
tolerate constant so everything here is
polynomial there is nothing special
but the reason I say what we mean by out
one over quality internally our polity
learning rate meaning that the learning
rate is of a 3d is a eighth highest
Newerth lower poly more due to the 10
something like but it's constant
yeah it's not constant power in the
polynomial yes
no no no I need to ago exponentially
stuck at some polynomial i quality to
the five years it will not go down by
too much even like the mini batches
yeah there's number if you have finite
number of samples and you can go to zero
you can go to zero but then you will
need like exponential or privatization
to go to the exact zero but go to a
universe polynomial you only need
polynomial
here what's the dependence of the
learning rate and number iteration yeah
there's no dependency I am well I guess
what is the power of yet with questions
so I'm can be larger this these powers
are arbitrary so I'm coming any
polynomial and it only can be some power
like essentially I'm can be larger than
all these powers are quite flexible and
also the learning rate are also quite
flexible so essentially there's no
dependency between the polynomials that
halt all those polynomials except for
the generalization error and the number
of iteration so for example M can be
larger than or can be smaller than and
also to simplify the analysis we note
that AI and wi+ scaling environment so
in this work we actually just repair a
mere as AI by the norm of W I so we only
need to consider twinning over WI
instead of two parameters WI on AI okay
that's simplification and then this is
not a neuro tangent kernel regime due to
the size of the random initialization
especially with by random initialization
we mean WI are just no Gaussian with one
word
I mean variance and so the AI has norm
well we routin but your tangent kernel
regime we require AI to have to have
absolute value approximately one so
that's the key difference between this
one's your tangent kernel yes right but
if you only really use these skills then
it's not an OK you can always use some
trick so it's an okay but if you speak
with this random initializations and
it's not anything but your learning rate
is also reasonable
yeah but random initialization matters
to decide whether it's n TK or not but
maybe we take his past
okay after besides a hard question yeah
thanks
so since it's not antique heads and what
why does over varmint receive your help
we actually present a new tool which is
a polynomial size coupling with a non
convex by infinity your own process and
DK is a convex and infinite importance
as a main difference so with sufficient
our parameterization actually the
optimization process of the network is
actually simulating a UV new neuron
process which is not convex but still
have a benign landscape that's okey and
the main difficulty is why the you
Fenian your own process has a better
training performance since it's not
convex and why is simulating the why
does the finite or parametrization
simulating the infinite or
parameterization with only polynomial
size over parameterization so that's the
men to men difficulty and so let's start
with the first one what is a UV neural
optimization process so for simplicity
just for this talk we focus on the case
that are equal to D so it's really a
unitary matrix and although AI starts
are positive like and all the AIS are
all positive so this is a simple case
and then ignoring the linear term in the
lost sense of population loss which is
an expectation of FX minus F star of X
is given by this formulation there's
some yeah so there's some difference
between the say each of the momentum of
WI and the momentum of the ground rules
so it's a known formula where the WI bar
is just a normalization of W and Sigma I
are like the hermit coefficient of
relish decreasing inverse with I so this
is kind of the lost formulation and that
random initialization
W is our Gaussian
now what is a youth in your own process
the infinite firm process is nothing but
you replace the summation of WI
everywhere by just expectation of debris
everywhere
or some distribution over our to a B so
this is a this is a different neuron
process and the original is a say you've
a neuron the distribution is just
Gaussian okay there is a scaling
difference here and here because this is
summation this is suspect Asian yes so
but you can distribute yeah you have a
distribution or nose instead of you have
a bunch of singleton nose you have that
distribution over all possible will be
working during yeah it will be evolving
over time just using your own process
now what is the youth in neuron evolving
process
so if a neuron processes you update this
probability distribution words or words
a gradient descent on each individual
ways individual node but each individual
node has zero contribution in the
expectation so how do you actually
define that you divide by you assuming
that the individual node has one unit
influence in the expectation so you have
determined like this term and so then
you will take gradient over we at the
point of tableau so it's more or less
you are pretending in the expectations
this neuron has white piece of
contribution instead of infinite I small
contribution so then you update the term
has a gradient so you can update it and
this is the youth in your own process
okay so it's kind of like doing eyes TD
or the distribution P and now it's going
to starting from here it's a little bit
technical and there's a loss function
has has two terms so there are zero term
and the second order term which looks
like this and ice wrong side these are
like matrix type of terms our PCA type
of terms they cannot identify W star
uniquely
they are
rotation environments who cannot use
them to learn WI star and then there are
some fourth-order oh you a higher order
term like this and these are cleanser
type of term just remember roams
pictures they are the terms that
identify ws are uniquely up to
permutations so these are the terms that
is good for learning WI stuff okay so so
it's a you thing so what is the special
about you in your optimization process
why is this easy to optimize the key
observation is that through the
optimization process the distribution of
P is always symmetric in the sense that
if you know the value of W J start ham
stabbed you for all the J not equal to I
and also absolute value of W J star
times W then the Sun Titan is going to
have a half probability at plus or minus
so it's like a symmetric distribution
over the base of WI star yes so that's a
here and it's easy to observe because
everything here are quadratic are like
even power of W so it doesn't really
matter what the sign of W and so the
distribution is symmetric and so with
this symmetric property that allows us
to simplify mal across firms from
calculating the gradient for example we
have expectation of tableaus start now
it just become correlation between wo
and WI star higher component and tensor
terminal also become much easier so yeah
this is just some illustrating example
you don't really need to understand that
but you just simplify a lot of
calculations with these sign symmetric
property so many cross terms that are
gone okay so now with this sign
symmetric property you can actually show
that after
a small number of iterations that zero
order and the second order term which
are the PC type of term will become very
small and they will become smaller than
the first order term and then the
optimization process centers the tensor
decomposition phase and then use the
tensor decomposition to identify
otherwise not correctly which means that
distribution will converge with some
single time distribution or WI starts
eventually using the tensor
decomposition face that can actually
identify double size start correctly so
the entire given your own process is
really a mixture of principal component
analysis and tensor decomposition and
this is super non convex it's not an TK
but still it has a good landscape okay
that's the key the key kind of
high-level proof structure of the given
your yes distributed to the world some
are N and this n is like number of like
second layer you like I know this
distribution is over tableau is always a
hidden Europe so you have a contribution
or that Rd but what do you say input
dimension yes you have a distribution or
the set of hidden so I guess like if you
stop Tanjung due to infinity isn't quite
easy to explain what this process turns
to in some way kind of doesn't matter we
are only considering finitely yeah
because T goes to infinity doesn't
really make sense because they will have
a you face like infinite self UV nice
format well with proper scaling of
course okay yes the ground truth neurons
are talking to each other
yes it's used in the previous slide
right that is very appropriate second
degree and second degree yes it's only
approximate then point a is also a
proximity metric you guys you can still
do something so we're like for random
neurons it should like for random I'm
not worried to exactly work but well
it's a rank of the neuron is much
smaller than the
like square root is and random neurons
door so so okay so I mean you really
need to use the fact that the number of
neurons is less than the ordinary in the
ground truth if they are random if they
are oh yes so you really need to use the
fact that no no actually the ground who
stabbed you I stars they can be
arbitrary
so the WI stars they can be Harvey for a
position but they are orthogonal all the
data is distributed according to caution
is for this formula to hold yeah you
don't use it again okay yeah like so you
try to generalize it to some other
distribution then you may have a change
of these formula hot buds so the basis
for me look cool like like do you feel
like if you change the suppose it's not
I probably go from Venus incoherence ice
for a tyrant proof is a little bit cool
because in fact different covariance is
like you have a blue eyes stars at the
whole nose of Juvenal and it will be a
bit tricky so now the real question is
how do we move from given neuron to a
finite neural with Stanley polynomial
size over time a transition so maybe
it's a 94 40s just to say my WI star is
the whole site is close to the food
distribution for example you watch this
and business and this is actually
impossible because it's a D dimension
distribution and it's enclosed to P
inverse si you have to have 2 to the D
number of neurons so it's not close at
all to P inverses and diesel and then
the naive approach is whether finite
neuron can preserve the key of the
region which is a size symmetric like
throughout the optimization process that
WI is approximately symmetric like if I
pick a random neuron like conditional
answers some heightens the value of all
everything
when coordinates and is a sign
approximate symmetric and turns out that
this is also not possible because if you
want to have some sign symmetry property
like for example WI stars are just yeah
it's a basis vectors and it just means
the style of each coordinate of W IRS in
our kind of symmetry then you will need
at least two to the Dean euros so it's
also not possible and also it's super
far away from being sizing matrix so
that you cannot really use this one to
simplify it across herbs explain the
phrase again can you go back to me in
the sense that for every are so alike
loss in the fringes maybe is kind of
like your condition on this which is
that the value of table UJ star and W I
so you know for duck for I retain those
people to our and also the absolute
value of tabular are W items tab you are
star so conditional the value of these
WI Terry hi Terry I've every direction
and absolutely okay yeah daddy was a
comma or it was afraid of okay so what
is a real way of companies are you in
urine dynamic this is Jesse I have W I
go through the gradient update I go
through this this this this so I start
from W I go to a some operator on W I go
to another operator and then there is a
finite numeral dynamic for each WI I
goes from wi i go from some operator on
wi and go to the second operator we as a
finite neurone STD which is so doing
gradient design on this problem and this
empirical loss
engine this is a real coupling which
says if my original W is equal to W so
is this even neural process close to the
given
process eventually at the last point if
I can show that I really coupled the to
process so you are actually covering the
entire optimization process so what is
the arrow for the first step for example
there are also go from WI to the
empirical version empirical step there
are actually three steps so you'll first
go from w1 at c1 of WI to G height one
of WI which is over family physician
arrow it's kind of like you're moving
from the distribution where P to a
sample of to us - I'm samples of WI from
the distribution of P so you have this
instead of the whole distribution and
then there is a sample arrow which means
that instead of having the real loss
formula you have said our height which
is an impure version of the loss so it's
not hard to see that this one scale with
more route time because you are sampling
I'm of the neurons from the distribution
and this one scale with one we routin
because you are sampling indeed has from
the distribution so here one word root
I'm is this true row of policies over
parameterization and this is like one
steps and the question is for many steps
like you'd you do you do many steps now
how does the arrow propagate and the
fundamental question is if the other
previous steps the arrow is absolute
then at the next step whether the arrow
becomes smaller like it's a contraction
or is it's become slightly larger or the
next step so you become much much larger
so for example the contraction is
typical for a convex problem you'll
start from something far away but then
you'll go to something close to each
other and super large amplification is
typical for non-convex process where you
start from this valley and but you
differ from it a little bit then you go
to the to this one do
directions so you have a very large
amplification on the coupling arrow and
the youth renewal process is a mixture
of PC and tensor dehumanization so is
highly non convex but fortunately as a
critical part of the proof what we are
we can show is that there is there are
some W where it is a exponential
amplification but for the most of the W
eyes it is mild amplification so by
mouth amplification we can see is like
more apologies so we can tolerate poor
edema number of iterations who reduce
the arrow to universe polity okay that's
the that's the polity where the polity
so together with an infant your own
process we can actually prove the final
theorem okay so here it's a yeah so this
is a result we actually show that the
runny eyes GDR or prama tries to learn
your network with radwa activation he
can learn a smaller two layer network
with rebel activation when the hidden
weights are orthonormal and data
distribution secure Cole Gaussian the
key messages the polynomial size over
parameterization is actually simulating
a youth in neuron process which has a
better landscape is a mixture of PC and
tensor decomposition and and say titled
landscape means that it's a symmetric
property of the distribution and the
MELD amplification property of the earth
and when the hidden weights are not also
normal and at least in the worst cases
required to to the d queries for the
IceCube model which means that you have
to have exponential wear
parameterization but also there are open
problem like whether it's not worst case
but close to or for normals or how can
you make this how what what kind of the
MELD assumption you can get yeah yeah
that's my talk
Thanks
other questions yes it's very
distinction with what you call infinite
no roll limit and min - what like min
field limit where you just take the
number of hidden most infinity and you
you analyze how the distributions get
updated and yeah I think our approach is
is exactly of that form but we define
like this sorry we define this update
wealth we define the distribution
updates how do you update the
distribution we had this formula and you
can define another other formula for
example you do gradient sounds and
distribution which might be different
from two ingredient he sounds a neural
individually and that one may be more
close to the Mules I'm not sure that's a
good question the Thriller in your net
it's a few more formula is going to be
super DV call that we don't really
relies on the fact that the witness that
would rectify linear functions yeah so
this is a simple example that is
actually tied to tool around it's not
practical to you relevance I would say
is just the proof of this example that
you show to the students and other over
parameterization works okay maybe one
last question okay let's think
Eunji again you can write okay so for
the final talk we're happy to have to
redraw from MIT you okay thanks final
final talk I'll be fast
hopefully I'll be fast so thanks for
sticking it out this talk is about again
in the regime of over parameterization
to talk about actually the memorization
capacity of reloj networks this is
work with my student charlie and my
colleague Elizabeth I and I should say
essentially all the as you can expect
all the actual work in this project is
done by Charlie who's sitting back there
so big thanks to him and the motivation
is of course I don't need to repeat this
but just mention this kind of
experimental motivation that many of us
are aware of that over parameterize
neural networks trained with SGD seem to
be able to memorize pretty much
arbitrary stuff and so one one
particular way to try to understand the
over parametrized phenomenon is to
understand the expressive power of a
neural network so for instance
classically expressive powers of neural
network is in ancient topic which goes
under the name of Universal
approximation theory but in neural
networks can kind of learn continuous
functions of a compact sets etc but
those results are kind of trying to
answer too much in the sense that okay
you're trying to just consider function
approximation so you're just trying to
learn the underlying function which
could have generated your data for
instance but they're not saying much
about finite samples we are trying to
focus here on memorization neural
network being able to overfit any
empirical given data regardless of
really learning and underlying concepts
so we are trying to understand that's
why the concept of memorization so we
want to carefully understand that pretty
much given any kind of training data how
how powerful is a neural network how
powerful does it need to be or how
powerful is a given neural network so
that is powerful enough to just memorize
the training data and so basically it's
connected to this expressive power
theory but now we have just focusing on
a finite set of training data that's
really the focus and so let me just
mention one a couple of simple
definitions so we'll just call finite
sample expressivity of a neural network
as the network's ability to satisfy the
following condition so you have
arbitrary essentially arbitrary training
data pairs X eyes and Y eyes and we will
say that if your neural network is able
to figure out parameters theta such that
it can exactly satisfy that equivalence
then we say the network has the power to
define our sample expressivity and I
look at now a special case where P is
the output dimension so less like
classification and simple regression we
will fit in there D is the input
dimension so we will say a memorization
capacity is the largest value so the
memorization capacity of a fixed
architecture that you're giving me of a
fixed architecture neural network to be
the largest value of n n is the size of
the training data for which the network
has perfect expressivity so I mean this
definition is simple but I hope it's
clear right
no can no contention here because I'm
just gonna casually now use the word
memorization capacity or memorization to
really refer essentially to this setup
for mostly I'll talk focus on the case
where the output dimension is 1 but the
many many related things not all can be
also said when the output dimensionality
is bigger than 1 like for instance
multi-class classification not only
vaguely related it is related this way
it's important to actually recall this
connection so memorization capacity I'm
just repeating this for this thing of P
equal to 1 is the largest n such that
for all data there exists the parameter
that you can fit in v c-dimension land
the maximum n for which there exists a
data set that can be shattered
essentially that you can be that you can
really fit exactly so
really the one of the core differences
is in the quantifiers there's some other
finer points that often the v
c-dimension theory is stated by adding
one more quantifier over all possible
architectures but I'm kind of blotting
that out the one major difference is
here so hence clearly memorization
capacity is going to is less than equal
to VC dimensions okay so classically
there has been work from prehistoric
times also on memorization so people
have studied memorization capacity of
neural networks with classical
activations like sigmoids etc relating
back to some construction from cover and
in many more more recently people have
also studied memorization ability of
reloj fully connected networks or of res
nets or of conv nets so there has been
related work on this topic but there is
something missing that many of the
recent studies on memorization capacity
of networks they can now make very
strong assumptions on the number of
hidden nodes and this thing came up
actually multiple times today like
Rongai mention about what he calls
mildly over parametrized or low over
parameterization even see also mentioned
there so for instance the strong
assumption which I call strong
assumption here is this type of result
which says the one here in Ray Lu so
this is a two layer network with one
hidden ray loon layer with n hidden
neurons can memorize any arbitrary data
set with endpoints so but the the width
is as large as the training data similar
stuff happens in other results that the
width and hence I am calling it width
but let's just say number of neurons the
number of nodes in your network if that
is the same size as the training data
that is extreme over parameterization
and we want to step away from extreme
over parameterization and talk about
memorization capacity when the over
parameterization is closer to what
wrong-way also mentioned as
mind over parameterization so rhetoric
question here for you can we use depth
to memorize with fewer than n neurons
and because it's a rhetoric question by
the theory of questions the answer to
this question is yes so I'll talk about
that in the interest of time actually
kind of plotted that stuff out is an
additional result we'll skip on the way
but I'll focus mostly on the
memorization capacity of fully connected
neural networks and by tight I mean both
lower and upper bounds on the number of
neurons so here is the so nobody to my
knowledge exploit the depth to reduce
the number of except for other types of
activations the sigmoid type of stuff so
there somebody has looked at I think to
layer and you but without we were
actually not even aware of that
originally so they know pros value and
really like so the we are trying to
remain close to the kinds of stuff
people use so here's the set up training
data and data items D dimensions P let's
just say P is equal to 1 so I'll
actually make an important assumption
but it's a mild assumption that all the
training data points are distinct if not
you can add them random perturbation but
let's the this is for the sake of
consistency and that all the Y's
I have scaled them to line that interval
minus 1 to 1 so here actually P is equal
to 1 it's just easier to describe that
and this is the standard neural network
architecture you have the activation at
each layer and that's the final network
output so and the activation we are
talking about looks like like yeah
really like activation so it includes
rail you as a special case and it has
some other value like activations
yeah moral regressions halo you can see
for classification we have also same
related results for classification
including for multi-class classification
no where in that case do you expect the
mapping to be just matching the signs or
exactly not exactly matching so
memorization really f theta of X has
exactly exact type so you have the exact
yeah but but memorization really means I
gave you XY pairs the network after you
push X through it has to spit out why
it's nothing to do in terms of loss
functions etc here okay so here is just
an illustration of kind of known stuff
for scalar regression you have d
dimensional input you put n hidden
neurons that was kind of the known
construction what we are now doing is
use power of depth
you put one hidden layer with square
root n neurons you put another hidden
layer with order square root n neurons
and using this you can again do perfect
memorization so now the number of hidden
neurons is square order of square root
of n rather than order of n
interestingly of course the number of
parameters or the number of edges in
your graph is o of n the size of the
training data but the number of hidden
neurons is much more civilized now
closer to reality the number of
parameters is the same because square
root n multiplied by square root n this
is no way to get around that so the main
first main result I deleted some
notation is a two hidden layer reloj
Network where the hidden layer
dimensionality so the first hidden layer
dimensional it is d one second hidden
layer dimensional it is d 2p is the
number the output dimension you can
think P is equal to 1 if it satisfies
this then it can memorize arbitrary data
sets as long as you satisfy your
assumption of that these points are
distinct so one of the practical reasons
for making the distinction assumption is
also to ensure consistency which
not you know you could have otherwise
bad training data where x1 is exactly
equal to X 2 but y1 is not equal to y2
tough luck learning with that but it's a
mild assumption so that's result on the
memorization power of rail networks that
with two hidden layers you can do that a
classification result which makes we add
another layer so you add a third layer
and then you can using the same type of
construction you can memorize arbitrary
classification data sets with P
different classes you don't need this
extra layer business if you are just
doing binary classification then the
same kind of stuff goes through so the
result holds also for multi-class
classification so that's the
memorization power that riilu networks
have which is pretty I think a pretty
interesting to see that ok square root
and width is more like the regime where
the network is already powerful enough
to memorize anything yeah you mean
that's the out of the know Network
exactly caught you that label or in fact
you think so you cannot max so that Arg
max business starts coming once you I
guess put some special choice on those
layers or something but what this means
is the f of theta the output will be
exactly why so what we are saying is we
can construct for you set of weights
weight matrices and bias vectors
whatever so that once you given those
X's we will output the Y's nobody will
use this of course but this is just to
show a very interesting counterpart now
to this sufficiency result is a
necessity result that if you are doing
this like P equal to 1 setting let if
you don't have enough hidden nodes if
you don't
enough neurons then there exists
datasets that your network cannot
memorize so with that you kind of get
both necessary and sufficient conditions
on the size of a neural network for it
to have the capacity to memorize
anything because square root n was
sufficient but from here you can see
that it's also necessary so let's let me
mention this in words again so if you
had width n with n neurons memorization
is easy you can do that but if you want
to make the size of the network the
number of hidden neurons to be more
realistic then the only way out is to
trade-off depth and width and already
adding just two hidden layers with order
of square root n suffices to do the job
and what we showed there in those two
necessary and sufficient results is that
necessary and sufficient condition on
wait for number of hidden neurons is now
you know essentially within a constant
factor of square root n number of
neurons will do the job it's both
necessary and sufficient and if you're
doing multi-class classification that's
the requirement for a two hidden layer
neural network the number on the number
of nodes but if you add one more layer
that requirement can be improved
so rather than multiply n with the
number of classes is just order of
constant times square root n plus
constant times number of classes so
that's the classification result also so
you very clearly see how adding depth
improves things here the third here
adding another layer basically the
construction is fairly simple it encodes
a P class classification problem into
suitable one hot encoding and then
solves it by a regression construction
the details are not
what in the really takeaway of the sighs
is the crucial thing here like a toy
illustration you know for instance
imagenet with ten a million data points
and thousand classes is already
perfectly memorize able with a pretty
reasonable sized network lower bounds
can you get them from VC the relation to
the VC dimension yeah so you get one of
them from exactly so I'll comment on
that also shortly yeah so so two layers
with so in terms of n the number of
parameters are so similar yeah the
number of parameters are still similar
okay so you're just arguing maybe in one
aspect and number neurons
maybe somebody cares in this case it
gives you a smaller width so really the
driving question for us was it's fine
that we you know which end you can do
the job
but we want to come closer to the sizes
that people are using in practice and
clearly in practice people are using
deeper and deeper networks which allows
them to actually use narrower networks
so what kind of width to be required to
do the job and this kind of square root
end dependence it can be refined further
if you allow me to make a deeper and
deeper and deeper network I think you
for being going wider and shower a
question about how do you trade off
depth versus waste
okay so let's let me just quickly is
that clock accurate yes but I what time
did I started I want to kind of finish
on time not over reach okay I think I'll
I zoom a bit through the proof ideas
it's a really clever construction made
by Charlie so let's just assume that
training data is like that and this is
the assumption I'll just call the
clipping region to be the complement of
the set way the labels live so
everything that lives outside that so
the original idea if you think of the
way you make width n guy do the job
roughly the high-level idea is you
essentially let each neuron here do the
work of memorizing one data point there
are multiple ways to do that but these
are if you think these are like Rea
loose then you have to tune the weights
appropriately so that if essentially
triggers only for x1 and kind of doesn't
trigger for the rest and here same thing
once you figure out how to do it for one
data point you can kind of repeat
inductively repeat the construction for
all the data points by carefully
selecting the weights and the point
being that here you have so many neurons
each neuron essentially then has enough
freedom of selecting the weights to
allow you to do the memorization for
each of the data points and the key
challenge in actually reducing the width
comes from the fact that now we need to
now we need to have each neuron in the
hidden layer be able to memorize square
root n points rather than one point or
rather not memorize take the burden of
memorizing square root n points H so
there's a bunch of encoding that has to
be done I'll try to quickly illustrate
at a very high level the nitty-gritty is
still in nitty-gritty so let's look at
case of four data points I'll just zoom
in I'm using hard ten H as the
activation there's just like bunch of to
ray loose so whatever I say here by
multiplying it by a factor of two the
same result will hold for array Lu
networks is just up to constant factor
of two so for n is four and let's also
make the following additional
pre-processing assumption important very
important that here is where I'm using
the points being distinct so all the x
i's are distinct so i don't project them
to a line by hitting them with a random
vector view or you can also carefully
select a deterministic variable and then
i sort them according to their values
and i reindex them so I read X so I just
read X those 1 2 3 4 so that this
property satisfied that that is part of
the construction now what I do is I
carefully tune weights so that this
neuron thresholds whatever corresponds
to X 3 and X 4 and keeps only step 4
corresponding to X 1 and X 2
whereas this neuron it takes the job of
keeping track of X 4 and X 3 while
thresholding X 2 and X 1 and so here you
can see there is so so this one goes
captures X 1 X 2 this one captures X 3 X
4 X 1 the the picture is supposed to
illustrate that
value coming here is smaller 4 X 1 then
it is 4 X 2 from that picture because
this is plus 1 and it's the in the
opposite order so there's a very careful
selection of which points are to be
encoded by which neurons and whose going
to be smaller than home and then next
these are the corresponding activations
of after you've applied the damage a
heart damage and now the most intricate
part of the proof actually comes here
which I'm actually going to skip the
details of that but only mention at a
very high level now what happens is each
of the next layer neurons it takes
responsibility for picking some point
from the previous layer and encoding its
corresponding Y I so what we do is this
layer this neuron it tries to perfectly
generate y1 so it tries to take
responsibility for x1 and it tries to
take responsibility for x4 so the rows
here in that matrix correspond to the
training data and the columns correspond
to the neurons the last line is the bias
term which I have set to 1 and so if our
only job is to perfectly fit Y 1 y 4 we
have 3 parameters but 2 unknown so we
have some bunch of freedom there to play
with the null space so the job of this
neuron is to is solve careful linear
system and very carefully select vector
in the null space so that the ones that
we want to fit exactly a fit exactly and
the others we can threshold so the
construction involves in there's a
clever choice in deciding which data
points are encoded by which neuron here
and the next careful choice is each
neuron here decides to prefer
we memorize which of the data points so
you see this one did X 1 X 2 this one
did X 3 X 4 but this one is memorizing X
1 label and this one is memorizing X
force label and there's a reason for
that I will comment on that very soon so
you do that you again here this one will
take care of memorizing X 2 X 3 s labels
and carefully selecting stuff in the
null space so that the others get
thresholded and this so so far this may
kind of look like some choices may look
arbitrary but there's a very important
reason for making this kind of
alternating choice like selecting how to
order them here and then from each of
this which one to repeat here so like
here we selected y 1 and y 4
corresponding to X 1 and X 4 here we did
X 2 X 3 is because if we don't do that
then or rather what we want to do that
what we want to do is that now what goes
out from this layer is y 1 and a 1 so
think of it this neuron for data point X
1 says y 1 this neuron for data point X
1 says threshold it at 1 so if you get Y
1 comma 1 that's the bias term this
neuron for Y X to say is a 1 this one
for X 2 say is a Y 2 and then you have a
bias in the same way the reason I'm
doing this now is because if you look at
it if I were to now just simply select
these as the weights connecting this
stuff to the output layer what is the
output corresponding to each data point
point we are able to generate here y1
plus 1 y 2 plus 1 by 3 plus 1 by 4 plus
1 so this very careful interleaving
allows us to output for each X I a
corresponding Y I plus 1 which is what
with
sorry are some bad wrong button got hit
here watch the animation in painful
detail
so that when you add them and then
remove the subtract the minus one
weighted bias you will have repeat
exactly perfectly why I threw yeah all
the Y's and this construction is I'm
only showing it for four points it's
actually a bit more slightly more
elaborate because here I only push
things two plus one I didn't show you
pushing things to the minus one regime
but the idea is very similar to
interleave odd and even in the right way
and then pick the points in the second
layer in the right way so that you can
actually get them to output Y I plus one
anyhow so the fact that all of this
works out is in the terrible details in
the paper and the job of the first layer
is to as I said pick points in this odd
and even alternating manner second
layers job is to select the indices of
which points to memorize and then by the
construction they get memorized and the
same idea can be generalized actually to
deeper networks and that extension is
possible let me skip the details so here
is the what we talked about so if I
should have written yeah so this this
one is in terms of parameters so coming
back to your comment Gregg on number of
parameters so if P is equal to one
actually theta of N parameter suffice to
memorize n data points which and this
and we showed that there's a lower bound
of Omega W on memorization kamay
capacity W is this the number of weights
all parameters in the network and then
there's a result of upper bound on VC
dimension of WL log W by Peter and
others which gives an almost tight upper
bound on memorization capacity assuming
the depth L is a constant so up to log
factors you know you get essentially
tight bound on memorization power let me
skip the stuff for res nets and am I out
of time okay cool so I'll just mention a
quick result so that was on the
memorization capacity of relu networks
and there was another
on memorization capacity of resinates
that are kind of skipped and something
that we are just beginning to
investigate so this is a very simplified
kind of result is the behavior of SGD
near memorizers and so this is the
standard setting we are using so we are
actually using here a strictly convex
differentiable etcetera loss function
and suppose you are at a memorizing
global minimum so suppose your network
is big enough that global minimum is
certainly going to memorize the data
then we analyze without replacement
stochastic gradient descent with
mini-bat size B so this is the SGD
update we run without replacement which
is again closer to the SGD that's
implemented in practice so it's doing
true-true without replacement sampling
so for that there's an informal result
which states the following if you
initialize your SGD pretty close to such
a memorizing minimum so memorizing
minimum is a global minimum right
because let's say the loss is
non-negative so there the loss will be
zero actually
so if the initialization of your SGD is
pretty close to the memorizing global
minimum then in a small neighborhood
because of those differentiability
etcetera properties and pushing away the
non differentiability of Ray Lu here
under the rug okay bear with me on that
it satisfies that we are within o of Rho
square this Taylor series expansion
close to theta star but the statement
then now if you run SGD from such an
initialization with a small enough step
size then your risk is going to become
ooofff Rho to the 4 but it's not a
complete result because it could also be
that what you could show is that ok then
after
we found the point theta we could only
show that the point theta is within two
times the original distance so it's not
that theta has come closer to theta star
the risk is guaranteed to be smaller but
after some point theta could also leave
the nice neighborhood
within which the dynamics and guarantees
of STD hold so it's kind of and the
restriction is on how small is that
neighborhood for which we can show the
risk shrinks quantifying that
neighborhood is seems to be very
challenging task but the good thing is
that this result is independent on of
any width depth distribution etcetera
assumption of stuff it only depends on
that your network is a has a glow
memorizing global minimum and once
through you have reached the part where
the risk shrinks to off that epsilon to
the for after that we could not analyze
what SGD does so actually understanding
the behavior of SGD without too many
more assumptions near a memorizing
minimum is still hard one remark I'll
mention before ending for people who
analyze STD one of the reasons we
actually use without replacement SGD
here is that because we train neural
networks in a pox and without
replacement SGD has a nicer property
that you do have a descent theorem after
an epoch and descent theorems are really
helpful for proving stuff about
shrinking the risk so I think given that
I will just stop here and mention to you
the archive preprint which lists all the
gory details of that stuff as well as a
bunch of other work we are doing on
neural networks so thanks
so maybe one week questions okay
les thanks for reaching in it
[Music]
[Applause]